hello guys we have some big news
regarding the future of spider-man so
according to a scooper my time to shine
hello she says after the reaction to no
way home sony want to make a movie with
toby andrew and tom together start to
finish now the actors themselves are
definitely interested in a movie of this
kind as recently in an interview
garfield said that he's more than eager
to continue working with co-stars
holland and mcguire and garfield is
keeping a door open should the right
idea make it worth to put the spidey
costume back on in terms of moving
forward with the character yes i am
definitely open to that garfield said
again it would have to be something very
unique very special and serving to an
audience and in service of the character
there's something playful and unique and
odd and unexpected to be done i'm not
sure what it is but if we can figure it
out it would be so much fun garfield
added i would love to continue working
with toby maguire and with tom holland
that kind of brother domanic is just so
juicy peter and spider-man those
characters are all about service to the
greater good and the many garfield said
he's a working-class boy from queens
that knows struggle and loss and is
deeply empathetic i would try to borrow
peter parker's ethical framework and
that if there was an opportunity to step
back in and tell more of that story i
would have to feel very sure and certain
in myself so there we have it so andrew
garfield himself is very interested in
doing another movie with toby maguire
and tom holland at least we've got the
actors on board and going back to that
scoop about um sony wanting to make a
movie with all three of them i think
there are definitely talks about this at
sony because no way home was such a huge
box office hit and this was drew and
covert as well so then making a whole
entire movie with all free spider-man
would just be such a huge hit that the
box offers and would make sony a lot of
money so i think they're definitely
thinking about making this movie so i
think there's actually some merit to
this scoop the big question is will they
actually go through with making this
movie because if this leak is true it
means there's only talks about this
movie there's nothing concrete about
them actually going to make it there
actually are more concrete rumors about
i'm a fourth spider-man film of tobey
maguire and the third amazing spider-man
film with andrew garfield being made so
possibly we'll see these films first
before all of the spider-man reuniting
again one of my big questions would be
how will they make these spider-man
reunite again because as we know the end
of nowhere home they went back to their
universes so how will they reunite would
a multiverse open up again or something
completely different honestly i'm not
sure how they would do it but i'm sure
there are many ideas they can come up
with to make enough same force but what
do you guys think if you see this film
how do you think they'll make all of the
spider-man reunite again let me know in
the comment section below if you haven't
already please like and subscribe and
turn notifications on to show your
support thanks for watching